قال الرئيس البيلاروسي الكسندر لوكاشينكو
انه تم بالفعل البدء بنقل اسلحه نوويه
تكتيكيه من روسيا الى بيلاروسيا واكد
لوكاشينكو في تصريحات لوسائل اعلام روسيه
ان الاسلحه النوويه ستكون امنه تماما
وبعيده عن ايدي المخربين بما في ذلك
بولندا وفق قوله من جانبه اعتبر الاتحاد
الاوروبي ان قرار بيلاروسيا نشر اسلحه
نوويه روسيه في اراضيها يضاعف التوتر
ويؤكد ضلوع مسك في حرب اوكرانيا
هذا وقع وزير دفاع روسيا وبيلاروسيا اليوم
اذا وثيقه تحدد اجراءات نشر اسلحه نوويه
تكتيكيه روسيه على اراضي بيلاروسيا وزير
الدفاع الروسي سرجا اعتبر ان الغرب يشون
حربا غير معلنه على دولتين واكد ان قرار
الرد في المجال النووي ياتي وسط تصعيد
كبير للتهديدات على الحدود الغربيه لروسيا
[تصفيق]
كانت ولا تزال حليفا حقيقيا وشريكا موثوقا
به واليوم نقف معا ضد الغرب الذي يقود
بشكل جماعي حربا غير معلنه ضد بلدينا
اذا البلدان الحليفان اتفقا على نشر اسلحه
نوويه تكتيكيه على اراضي بيلاروسيا اضافه
لاسلحه ومقاتلات روسيا نعود للوراء قليلا
ففي السادس والعشرين من مارس اعلن الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين الناموسكو ستنشر
هذه الاسلحه النوويه في بيلاروسيا وقال ان
النشر لا ينتهك معاهده عدم انتشار الاسلحه
النوويه وما عدم توفر احصاءات رسميه قدرت
المخابرات الامريكيه ان روسيا تمتلك ما
يقرب من الفي سلاح نووي تكتيكي هذه
الاسلحه عباره عن رؤوس حربيه نوويه صغيره
مخصصه للاستخدام في ساحه المعركه لتدمير
اهداف العدو في منطقه معينه دون احداث
تداعيات تداعيات مثل اشعاع واسع النطاق
روسيا لم تكتفي فقط بنشر الاسلحه بل ارسلت
وسائل اطلاقها نتحدث هنا عن تجهي
المقاتلات سوخوي 25 لحمله معدات نوويه بعد
التدريب الطيارين البيلاروسيين عليها ايضا
اتفقت موسكو ومسك على نشر منظومات اس 400
وصواريخ اسكندر ام التي يمكن استخدامها
للصواريخ التقليديه والنوويه طبعا صاروخ
اسكندر ام تفوق سرعته سرعه الصوت وبامكانه
الوصول لارتفاع 50 كيلومترا وبماذا يصل
الى 500 كيلومتر وتقول روسيا ان صواريخ
اسكندر قادره على المناوره وتجنب الصواريخ
المضاده للصواريخ الباليستيه وايضا تدمير
مختلف الاهداف الثابته اضافه للاسلحه التي
تم نشرها تعمل روسيا وبيلاروسيا على زياده
الاستعداد القتالي
للجيشين كما سيتم نشر وحدات عسكريه اضافيه
وتشير روسيا وحليفتها بيلاروسيا الى ان
التحركات الاخيره لا تخالف اي التزامات
دوليه وانها رد على ما اسمته بالنشاط
العسكري العدواني
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات